today I want to reveal to you the secret
to getting better at talking to people
so the first thing you have to
understand is that you were not born
socially handicapped we humans are a
very social species so much in fact that
you can take a baby and put him or her
in a room full of people and over time
he or she will learn to speak purely
through observation and this is because
the human brain is actually extremely
good at identifying patterns and rules
when it comes to social interactions the
reason your social skills aren't that
great is simply because you haven't
given your brain enough time to observe
interactions and become fluent in all of
the patterns and rules in short you lack
practice the secret to getting better at
talking to people or learning any
language is to Simply get more practice
to interact with more people to give
your brain more opportunities to observe
and learn the unique patterns and rules
of this language so just go out there
and start talking to more people that's
the secret